bonjour J'ai le plâtre bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité politique
ce matin merde de Chalon-sur-Saône
vice-président des République en étant
sans pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Fabrice
vessarodon votre presse régionale les
journaux de l'Est de la France groupe
Ebra bonjour Fabrice bonjour
on va évidemment commencer par l'Italie
c'est l'information de cette nuit
victoire de Georgia mélony pour la
première fois depuis 1945 un parti post
fasciste arrive au pouvoir elle est en
tête des élections comment réagissait ce
résultat je réagis déjà en seulement un
moment donné la décision du peuple
italien c'est pas un accord de principe
sur le programme mais je pense qu'il
faut parce que je fais écho à un débat
qui s'est élevé avec les propos de la
président de la Commission européenne
cette semaine on ne contraint pas
disposait de tous les outils si jamais
très clairement très clairement dans ce
débat national italien fait preuve
d'ingérence c'est-à-dire que on peut
vouloir instaurer des garde-fous et
d'ailleurs tout gouvernement respecter
les règles démocratiques ça sera une
vigilance sur celui-ci pas celui qui va
venir comme sur tous les autres en
Europe mais avant le résultat de
l'élection
osez dire que brandir la menace pour
essayer d'influencer le scrutin c'est
quelque chose qui ne faut plus jamais
refaire un peu plus et je pense à mon
avis c'était un magnifique coup de pub
pour les la coalition qui maintenant va
arriver au pouvoir mais c'est surtout la
dernière des choses à faire dans un
moment où les peuples européens sont
très sceptiques sur le fonctionnement
même de des institutions européennes
donc voilà c'est mon premier réaction
c'est de dire le peuple italien est
indépendant il est souverain et il a
décidé souverainement voilà vous avez
une approche souverainiste du sujet
je crois très sincèrement je suis
fondamentalement et d'ailleurs c'est un
débat on va sans doute parler des
républicains tout à l'heure c'est un
débat qui va être central parce que on
peut toujours s'interroger sur savoir
qui va présider au dessiner des
républicains mais si on n'est pas clair
sur ce qu'on veut pour l'Europe qui est
notre prochain grand scrutin on arrivera
à rien donc oui
vous pouvez me dire que je suis attaché
à la souveraineté je suis
fondamentalement européen mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'Europe telle qu'elle
fonctionne avec des prises de position
notamment de la président de la
Commission européenne qui sont largement
des excès de pouvoir par rapport au
prérogatives qui sont les siennes sont à
bannir donc c'est pas cette Europe là
que nous souhaitons et en tout cas cette
Europe-là les peuples la rejette ou du
moins l'ignore parce que le résultat
italien montre bien que on influence pas
le choix d'un peuple et c'est ça qui
compte raisonnement
en Italie je ne sais très honnêtement
pas si cette coalition va sauver plus
Italie que la précédente je vous le dis
d'ailleurs dans la précédente collision
celle qui est encore au pouvoir
aujourd'hui avec autour de Monsieur
Draghi on avait déjà des mouvements
d'extrême droite intérieur la Ligue fait
partie de la coalition qui a amené
monsieur Draghi à avoir une majorité à
l'Assemblée italienne donc on voit bien
que c'est pas pour autant que la
situation italienne est reluisante enfin
je faut juste qu'on regarde les
situations italienne précisément c'est
pour ça que je vous dis je suis très
sceptique sur le résultat je ne sais pas
si ça sera mieux qu'avant mais je dis
simplement que vous aviez ça vous
inquiète pas qu'un parti d'extrême
droite dirige la
troisième
c'est la Ligue du Nord donc à partir de
là j'ai pas plus d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui que j'en avais hier la tête
change ça n'est pas rien avec avec une
histoire avec un passé mais j'ai lu les
déclarations
il faut travailler avec ce nouveau
gouvernement c'est aujourd'hui le choix
du peuple italien il se respecte on la
France n'a pas à dire je prends je
laisse c'est le choix du peuple
républicain français accepté de
travailler ou pas avec ses études là je
suis même je vais pas vous le cacher
j'ai lu comme vous avez pu le faire des
déclarations de la future première
ministre parce que c'est ainsi que les
choses vont se passer notamment sur un
passé fasciste italien dont elle a eu du
mal en tout cas une époque à se détacher
voilà en disant que Monsieur Mussolini
en particulier était le plus grand
politicien des de la dernière génération
ou des dernières générations Italie
j'avoue que cette déclaration est de
nature à me troubler je ne crois pas que
Monsieur Benito mussolin soit un modèle
politique même si je le juge comme
français et pas comme italien pour
autant encore une fois soyons bien clair
si nous respectons les peuples ne
respectons leurs décisions le peuple
italien a choisi à plus de 40% de
données une majorité à cette coalition
et par conséquent c'est elle qui va
conduire le dessin d'Italie la France ne
peut pas faire comme si rien n'a changé
elle doit donc travailler avec les
autorités ténériennes telles qu'elles
soient et on en a en plus besoin dans
une période de fragilité pour l'ensemble
de nos pays mais je le dis nous devons
travailler aussi d'État état et pas
simplement sur le couvert de l'Union
européenne et ça c'est effectivement la
vision souveraine que j'ai de la
politique et puisqu'on va parler des
républicains est-ce que cette coalition
droite extrême droite comme en Italie
vous l'imaginez en France vous la
souhaitez non je pense que les cinq
situations nationales et singulière
c'est bien sûr la tentation est forte et
d'ailleurs on va je pense vous êtes la
première aujourd'hui à poser la question
et il y en aura d'autres qui le feront
parce que on a vu ce qui s'est passé en
Scandinavie en Suède en particulier on
vient de voir ce qui se passe en Italie
est-ce que les choses sont
reproductibles en France d'abord enfin
écoutez moi il faut tout de même qu'on
regarde les choses on s'appuie sur des
personnalités en politique le système
politique français est complètement
centralisé sur l'élection présidentielle
ça n'est pas le cas en Italie vous avez
une coalition c'est ce qu'elle veut oui
mais ce que je veux simplement dire
c'est que vous avez une coalition de
partie et qui est en train de gagner
l'élection en tout cas les résultats le
montre ce matin en France tout dépend de
l'élection présidentielle est-ce que
vous croyez que aujourd'hui la
principale force politique de ce bloc
que certains voudraient voir se dessiner
ce qu'on appelle l'Union des droites
c'est-à-dire en l'occurrence Marine Le
Pen moi je regardais résultats c'était
le cas le meilleur score à l'élection
présidentielle est-ce que
tapant sur tout ce qui n'est pas
reconquête j'en ai j'en fais aussi les
frères régulièrement donc c'est pas
c'est une drôle de façon de voir l'Union
des droites mais je prends simplement le
cas d'école est-ce que vous croyez
sincèrement que Madame Le Pen peut être
rassurant dans sa capacité à présider
destiné la République française moi je
réponds non je l'ai toujours dit elle
est aujourd'hui elle n'est pas à mes
yeux en tout cas en capacité de présider
au destiné de la République donc comment
voulez-vous imaginer se projeter sur un
système c'est à dire que si demain ce
n'est plus Marine Le Pen la candidate du
rassemblement national mais un autre
candidat là il faudra réfléchir à une
coalition entre le rassemblement
national et la deuxième hypothèque à
lever dans ce cas-là imaginez je prends
l'hypothèse je la pose sur la table mais
est-ce que vous croyez une seule seconde
qu'on peut s'entendre sur le plan de la
politique économique nous avons des
points d'accord en tout cas moi je peux
m'en reconnaître avec un certain nombre
d'autres parties de droite des points
d'accord sur la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière des points
d'accord sur la lutte contre l'islamisme
qui gangrène notre société et
guichiwoody je vous le dis même sur le
terrain qui est en train de galoper
aujourd'hui qui galope sur le terrain
donc ça on peut s'entendre sur un
certain Monsieur en tout cas on voit
bien qu'il y a des points d'accord mais
fondamentalement moi je ne vois pas de
différence notable entre le programme
économique du rassemblement national et
le programme économique de partie de
gauche notamment autour de Monsieur mél
et ça c'est juste pas possible pour nous
donc voyez bien que on peut pas
transposer un système italien suédois
sur le système français voilà certes
mais vous savez aussi comme nous que
l'Italie a souvent 10 années d'avance
sur ce qui se passe en France on a une
inventé du mouvement 5 étoiles on a eu
Berlusconi avant Sarkozy on a eu Renzi
avant Macron est-ce que ce qui est en
train de se passer en Italie n'est pas
inéluctable mine de rien en France alors
je alors je suis historien de formation
donc je suis très sensible mais
à l'écho que vous faites effectivement à
ce qui a pu préfigurer une situation
française il y a quelques années mais je
sais aussi une chose c'est que
l'histoire n'est jamais écrite par
avance et si nous sommes à certains
nombre à nous battre sur des idées qui
sont celles de la droite républicaine
même si aujourd'hui nous sommes dans les
cordes sur le plan électoral c'est que
nous croyons que ces idées peuvent
demain être le pivot d'une alternance en
France donc je ne suis pas aujourd'hui
dans une logique d'union telle que vous
la décrivez je pense que il faut rebâtir
une droite républicaine et que c'est
autour de cela qu'on peut gagner la
confiance du peuple français aujourd'hui
je le dis très clairement vous n'avez
pas une majorité d'ailleurs on l'a vu à
la dernière présidentielle même contre
Monsieur Macron qui était très largement
rejeté dans l'opinion publique il a été
élu faute de mieux pourquoi parce que
Madame Le Pen n'est pas de nature à
rassembler une majorité de français
derrière elle on parlez de rebâtir la
droite républicaine est-ce que elle doit
se rebâtir autour de vous est-ce que
clairement vous êtes candidat à la
présidence des républicains je suis
toujours en réflexion sur ce sujet oui
effectivement je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que je crois aujourd'hui que nous
avons un enjeu qui est un enjeu vital et
comme je vois les choses se dessiner en
ce moment je pense que les républicains
sont en danger de mort et d'ailleurs
cette histoire de d'élection contestée
devant les tribunaux dont on nous promet
qu'elle va développer cette histoire un
feuilleton judiciaire avec d'autres
recours vous avez vu comme moi Virginie
calmez dans le Figaro hier nous le dire
montre bien que cette famille
elle avait quand même des billes pour
dire qu'elle pouvait être candidate moi
je suis pas à la place du tribunal mais
je crois quand même qu'on a été un peu
léger dans la décision d'exclusion qu'on
lui a opposé et aujourd'hui elle se
retrouve dans une position de force qui
peut demain aboutir à faire annuler tout
le scrutin si elle le souhaite et il me
semble d'ailleurs qu'elle est un peu
déterminée alors que franchement je le
dis est-ce que Madame Calmel c'était un
danger et pour qui la démocratie c'est
précisément qu'on puisse se présenter je
suis passé c'est pas du tout un
ralliement parce que elle ne défend pas
ma ligne voilà je la trouve beaucoup
trop macronienne ça c'est très clair
mais à un moment donné vous devez
accepter que les gens se présentent là
visiblement il y a eu un excès de
rigueur la concernant il y a une faute
la part de la direction de la République
la justice le dirham en tout cas elle
semble penser qu'il y en a une parce que
pour décision oui moi je vois aussi les
conséquences juridiques si vous voulez
je pense que effectivement on aurait dû
être beaucoup plus souple parce qu'on
l'a été par le passé parfois on avait
des candidats qui étaient un petit peu
border sur quelques conditions et on les
a laissé venir pour justement enrichir
le scrutin et là on a fait le mouvement
inverse on a fait preuve de rigidité
mais le problème dans tout ça c'est pas
tant madame Calmel c'est l'image que
nous renvoyons est-ce que c'est l'image
d'une famille politique qui va bien que
au moment où elle renouvelle ses
instances elle va rentrer dans un
feuilleton judiciaire donc oui la
question de la candidature est encore
posée mais j'allais dire presque quelque
part elle est elle est presque
secondaire par rapport à cette question
vitale donc je vous tranchez pas j'ai le
plâtrer les candidats sont lancés vous
l'avez dit c'est déclaré Aurélien
Pradier c'est d'être sûr pourquoi vous
vous ne vous déclarez pas qu'est-ce qui
va vous décidez ça vous a pas échappé
donc simplement on peut toujours dire on
y va un coup de bluff etc pour y aller
et pour faire prospérer une candidature
faut qu'un certain nombre de conditions
soient réunies donc il faut un dialogue
notamment des parlementaires ce dialogue
je l'ai en ce moment il faut un dialogue
avec les autres candidats déjà déclaré
ce dialogue je l'ai j'ai rencontré
lentement
un dialogue ou des parrainage mais ça va
avec ecoutez
vous n'aurez aucun chiffre de ma part
sur cette question ah oui bien sûr je
sais bien je sais que je vous contrarie
en disant cela mais la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si ma
candidature peut enrichir ou pas le
débat moi j'ai j'en fais pas j'en fais
pas une affaire de personne il faut être
très modeste on m'avait dit éclater en
disant est-ce que vous pouvez sauver les
républicains je pense que personne ne
peut sauver seul les républicains
aujourd'hui je défends que si vous
réfléchissez encore ça veut dire que
dans les candidats déjà déclarés il y en
a aucun qui ne vous satisfait en tout
cas il y en a beaucoup qui m'intéressent
je peux le dire autrement mais est-ce
que je retrouve tout ce que je veux
défendre en eux sans doute pas
vous êtes quand même sur des lignes qui
sont extrêmement proches lui-même
que Laurent Wauquiez
non mais je vois pas de différence
notable honnêtement entre les enfin je
vais aller on va on va prendre les trois
candidats déclarés il y en a d'autres
encore une fois Éric Ciotti nous avons
des positions régaliennes très très
proches Bruno retaillod je ne me sens
pas contradiction du tout avec les
positions que défend Bruno Retailleau
j'ai plus de difficultés avec Aurélien
Pradier qui défend une ligne qui est une
ligne de centre droit qui qui est moins
la mienne et je le respecte en disant ça
les choses ne sont pas du tout une
critique dans ma bouche simplement je
pense fondamentalement que comme partie
d'opposition nous devons et c'est
peut-être la différence que je mettrai
dans ce débat nous devons être
intransigeants avec le gouvernement je
vais jusqu'au bout de mon propos si nous
devons ouvrir le dialogue avec toute la
droite parce que je pense qu'il a besoin
de dialoguer dans ce y compris
d'ailleurs avec une droite qui n'est pas
fondamentalement la nôtre moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ait des dialogues y
compris avec la droite macronienne vous
voyez ce que je veux dire mais je suis
un opposant intransigeant et je pense
que ce gouvernement fait du mal à la
France et que nous vont être en capacité
demain de voter une mention on ne
censure pour le renverser je n'ai pas
entendu ça encore dans la bouche des
autres candidats moi je crois très
sincèrement
pour faire tomber le gouvernement c'est
ce qui me correspond et je pense que
c'est aussi ce qui correspond à ce que
les électeurs nous ont demandé de faire
lorsqu'ils ont voté pour nous lors des
élections législatives est-ce que les
députés renversés le gouvernement est-ce
que vous avez vous avez sauvé un groupe
qui est quand même assez important à
prendre le dernier est-ce qu'en cas de
nouvelle élection vous auriez le même
groupe ah mais ça c'est toujours
l'inconnu de l'avenir mais la vraie
question c'est est-ce qu'il faut se
baser sur le sentiment qu'on a qu'on
fera mieux à une prochaine élection si
il devait y avoir une dissolution
suivant une motion de censure ou si ce
qui compte avant tout c'est l'intérêt de
la France moi je pense que l'intérêt de
la France commande que ce gouvernement
soit stoppé dans sa marche on aura sans
doute une occasion c'est ça aussi la
question mais mais quand vous faites le
jeu parlementaire là aussi je parle dans
cette maison qui le connaît bien le jeu
parlementaire c'est pas d'écrire tout à
l'avenir c'est simplement de tirer et
c'est le rôle du Parlement dans une
démocratie c'est de tirer la
responsabilité de ceux qui possèdent le
pouvoir exécutif en l'occurrence le
gouvernement ce gouvernement ne
travaille pas dans l'intérêt des
Français il ne mérite donc pas la
confiance de la nation juste à un
dernier mot sur l'orientation des
républicains est-ce que pour vous ça
doit toujours être un parti de la droite
et du centre où ça doit être un parti
plus à droite et exit le centre non
c'est pas exit le son nous avons une
vocation naturelle à travailler avec le
centre mais je pense que ce travail ne
doit pas se faire à l'intérieur de la
maison il doit se faire dans le cas
d'alliance électorale et je crois que
nous nous sommes très clairement dilués
parce que on a la logique de Jacques
Chirac quand il y a création du MP
remontons à ça parce que c'est bien
là-dessus que nous rassemblons à un
moment donné le RPR et l'UDF est
quelques autres composantes bien
évidemment mais cette logique là est une
logique parlementaire il fallait
rappelons-nous dans le contexte de
l'époque fallait calmer le jeu notamment
l'assemblée face à une majorité qui
était un peu tonitruente et remettent
tout le monde dans le rang bon ça a joué
sur le plan tactique remarquablement
mais sur le plan idéologique ça nous a
terriblement affaibli pourquoi parce que
quand vous avez dans la même journée
quelqu'un qui fait une proposition j'en
ai fait les frais d'ailleurs le matin un
peu fort dis proposition de droite telle
que moi je l'estime être encore une fois
j'ai pas la science infuse mais quand je
dénonce par exemple un phénomène
d'épuration éthique dans les quartiers
j'ai une vision regalienne des choses et
je le dis et que l'après-midi même vous
êtes condamné au nom d'impératif Moreau
par des gens qui travaillent avec vous
dans le même parti politique mais il ne
faut pas s'étonner dans ce cas-là que 95
% des Français ne nous écoutent plus à
l'élection présidentielle donc je
préfère de loin à partie de droite
assumée qui travaille parce que ça c'est
la nature même de notre jeu politique
qui travaille avec des formations
centrist assumées dans le cas d'un
programme de gouvernement mais pas dans
le même parti il y a une question qui va
se poser au Républicain très rapidement
c'est faut-il voter ou non la réforme
des retraites elle était dans le
programme de Valérie Pécresse se report
de l'âge de départ est-ce que les
républicains les députés les
républicains doivent la voter les
sénateurs également nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui à revenir ce que nous avons
sur ce que nous avons constamment
défendu la vraie question aujourd'hui
c'est pas savoir s'il faut reporter
l'âge nous savons tout ce qu'il le faut
la vraie question c'est de savoir de
quelle manière on le fait vous savez que
par exemple au Sénat régulièrement un
amendement a été voté par la majorité
sénatoriale sans espoir d'aboutir
jusqu'à présent dans le projet de loi de
finances sociales voilà exactement
dans le budget de la Sécurité sociale
les parlementaires les républicains
doivent voter c'est là où les choses
sont différentes c'est quand vous avez
un rôle et c'était le cas précédemment
pour essayer de d'imposer un débat dans
le public vous avez le rôle de
l'amendement parce que ça c'est l'arme
qui dont disposer les sénateurs jusqu'à
présent mais aujourd'hui que tout
simplement a priori si je crois lire
mais c'est des fois confus les
intentions macroniennes se débat va
quand même venir au Parlement nous nous
souhaitons dans ce cas là qu'on est le
temps quand même dans débattre pas
simplement sous forme d'un amendement
parce que l'amendement venant d'une
opposition qui impose un débat que
refuse la majorité c'est pas la même
chose qu'un débat que la majorité veut
poser sur la table du Parlement donc il
faut du temps il faut du temps et je
pense en plus il y a une attaque sur le
fond mais pas sur la forme en fait il y
a pas de désaccord ou pas puisqu'on ne
sait pas quel sera vraiment la méthode
aujourd'hui du gouvernement j'ai bien
entendu qu'il y avait des débats au sein
même de la majorité moi je pense que
face au pays la meilleure des méthodes
c'est pas l'amendement même si c'était
ce que l'opposition de droite avait
essayé de faire le jour dans les vous
voulez plus c'est un projet de loi mais
ça veut dire que ce projet de loi les
parlementaires à l'air doivent le voter
si ça acte le report de l'âge de départ
en fonction alors le diable est dans le
détail quand vous commencez à rentrer
dans le détail de ce texte c'est
beaucoup moins simple qu'il n'y paraît
nous nous avons un principe c'est
finement pour équilibrer les comptes le
report de l'âge est une et sans doute le
meilleur moyen aujourd'hui mais quand on
va commencer de rentrer dans les
retraites complémentaires dans la
pénibilité etc vous allez voir la
difficulté donc il faut un débat
parlementaire en tout cas ça se tranche
pas par un seul amendement une question
sur le budget
autre volet important de la réforme des
réformes présidentielles vous entendez
aller jusqu'au blocage avec le
gouvernement je pense que là c'est pour
le coup c'est clair il y a pas
d'ambiguïté je me suis parfois désolé
que lors des mois de juin et juillet
finalement en essayant d'être au bon
élève on amène des amendements et on
vote des textes qui a donné au
gouvernement une majorité qu'il n'a pas
l'assemblée c'était que c'était
consensuel je pense au pouvoir d'achat
etc
mais là c'est très simple dans toute
démocratie à quelques niveaux que ce
soit si vous votez un budget vous
rentrez dans la majorité acte fondateur
c'est l'acte fondateur de la majorité et
de l'opposition
il dit les symboles politiques n'ont
jamais rempli le frigo des Français oui
et puis surtout les symboles politiques
peuvent parfois défaire des
gouvernements c'est ce qui inquiète
beaucoup Monsieur Attal voilà donc
aujourd'hui je pense que les choses sont
très claires j'ai entendu Bruno
Retailleau j'ai entendu Olivier Marley
j'ai entendu d'autres responsables les
républicains que ce soit au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée voteront contre le projet de
loi de finance c'est l'acte fondateur
nous restons dans l'opposition donc
après on verra ce qui se passe il y a
engagement de responsabilité il pourra y
avoir une motion de censure et c'est là
qu'on revient à mon souhait qui est le
mien de renverser le gouvernement
puisque vous êtes maire il y a une
inquiétude sur ce budget sur la question
des collectivités à la face à la hausse
des prix de l'énergie est-ce que dans ce
contexte l'Association des maires de
France à laquelle vous appartenez à eu
raison de se rendre au Conseil national
de la refond moi je ne l'aurais pas fait
voilà très clairement je pense que cette
une façon pour le président de reprendre
la main comme il l'a fait au moment des
grands débats du grand débat qui a suivi
les gilets jaunes j'avais d'ailleurs
refusé d'y participer à cette époque là
ma ligne n'a pas changé je pense que on
n'est pas là pour participer aux
opérations de communication du Président
de la République lorsqu'il est en
difficulté politique c'est exactement le
même schéma donc je ne l'aurais pas fait
pour autant
c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup
mais je pense qu'en tout cas j'arrive
c'est lui qui a des option différente
très clairement je n'y aurais pas
participé comme d'ailleurs je vois que
de grands personnages dans cette maison
du Sénat ont refusé également d'y
participer et ils ont eu raison
Saône-et-Loire la rentrée avec vos
troupes les républicains vous avez vous
êtes revenu sur ce sujet qui était cher
l'islamisme je reprends une de vos
phrases
notamment faisait référence à ce qui se
passe en Iran l'enjeu n'est pas kiranien
dites-vous l'islamiste l'islamisme gagne
du terrain dans notre société jour après
jour vous avez également dit hier vous
m'arrêter c'est une bêtise qu'à vos yeux
le voile et le symbole par excellence de
la soumission on en revient au sujet de
tout à l'heure qu'est-ce qui aujourd'hui
vous distingue de la politique du
rassemblement national j'en sais rien
très honnêtement sur ce sujet enfin
c'est même pas une question quand je dis
j'en sais rien c'est pas une question
que je me pose la vraie question je me
pose c'est est-ce que nous sommes
capables dans une société qui est à la
fois l'héritière de la Révolution
française qui a amené les libertés et de
l'humanisme la Renaissance qui a mis
l'homme et la femme bien évidemment je
fais attention à ce que je dis en ce
moment parce que le sujet est un peu est
un peu tendu mais quand je dis l'homme
au sens de l'humanisme c'est évidemment
l'humanité l'individu au centre du
projet politique et bien nous avons face
à ces deux héritages la révolution d'à
côté l'humanisme de l'autre nous avons
une contre révolution qui est à l'oeuvre
qui s'appelle l'islamisme c'est un
projet politique et la première le
premier espace de visibilité que le
projet islamiste se donne dans en France
de forcer les femmes à porter le voile
c'est-à-dire à se soumettre à l'ordre
patriarcal le mari et le père avant donc
ça ce n'est pas un modèle français je
pense qu'il contrarie fondamentalement
les idéaux qui sont les nôtres et je
crois très sincèrement qu'il va falloir
que nous ouvrions les yeux je suis
favorable à ce que nous interdisions à
certains d'idéologie dans ce pays c'est
à dire les Frères musulmans d'un côté le
salafisme de l'autre nous pouvons le
faire on me dit on peut pas interdire
une idéologie si on l'a fait le nazisme
aujourd'hui est interdit et depuis la
guerre est interdit vous ne pouvez plus
le professer vous ne pouvez plus vous en
revendiquer or les Frères musulmans qui
sont des mouvements liberticides peuvent
encore avoir pignon sur eux dans ce pays
donc quand on aura interdit ces
mouvements là et pour moi c'est une
nécessité il faudra interdire ensuite la
manifestation par laquelle ils occupent
l'espace public et il comprennent des
femmes à se soumettre alors que ça n'est
pas les idéaux français donc c'est pour
ça que la question du voile arrive dans
le débat et ça n'est pas qu'une question
iranienne d'ailleurs vous voyez bien le
symbole de la liberté pour ces femmes
qui ont vécu pendant plus d'une
génération on va dire une grande
génération depuis la révolution de
comédie c'est précisément de brûler leur
voile et de montrer leurs chevelure et
quand on aura quand on comprend ça on
peut pas dire mais c'est magnifique ce
qui se passe en Iran moi je soutiens ce
mouvement on l'a affiché d'ailleurs une
énorme banderole sur le l'hôtel de ville
de Chalon-sur-Saône en soutien à ce
mouvement de liberté et on ne peut pas
dire d'un côté mais écoutez bah en
France non mais c'est la liberté le
voile comme certains mouvements essaient
de nous le faire croire je pense au
planning familial ou autre donc il y a
une logique à avoir le voile et l'ennemi
de la liberté il faut donc l'interdire
cette manifestation ne peut pas rester
comme finalement l'étendard de la
soumission parce que derrière tout ça il
y a un projet politique l'islamisme
c'est pas la foi c'est le projet
politique appuyé sur la foi donc nous
devons être en tout cas plus fort que et
les interdire merci Gilles patrie merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin merci Fabrice de Serreau dans la
semaine prochaine on passe au club des
territoires
[Musique]